[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god i'm so sorry that was purely
reacted
oh
[Applause]
come on
i got you come
on oh my god
oh my god hey
a part of wait for me did you knock in i
said i'm coming with you okay
okay
we're looking for the age of explorers
exhibit so be quiet volume
that's my last piece i'll split it
hey
punk
all right smart guy
who's this too easy for an amateur
first guy to sail around the world
wrong
angela never made it all the way around
you just took all the credit
holy there it is
what
come here
first map of the whole world
you know what magellan was really
looking for
gold
but
he never made it home
so all that gold
is just gone oh
lost
now gone there's a difference
if something's lost
it can be found
but lucky for us we got pirate blood in
our veins descended from sir francis
drake himself
at least that
was what mom and dad used to say
you know
sometimes i think they're out there
somewhere
like they're just lost they're not lost
they're gone
all right
this map is worth a fortune
here goes
nothing go hey hey youtube
don't move oh crap
[Music]
we came here first out of respect sister
b
but this is his third strike
go get your thing sam
you can't just let them take him away
say you goodbyes
what the hell
i'm not letting them lock me up
no way
i'm coming with you
not this time
come here
you see me go anywhere without this
no
so you know i will never leave it behind
i will always
be with you
says sick parvus magna
greatness from small beginnings
that's you and me
i better go
[Music]
i'll come back for you nate
promise
never forget your drake
i love you
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh well well well if it isn't the late
great and formally employed name well
she got the great part right
hey goldie i brought your stuff up thank
you hey how was last night great yeah he
was cute very cute nice
hi hi
excuse me
sorry
what can i get you that pocket tonic
vodka tonic come on it's my first drink
of the night test me a little oh i don't
know uh negroni oh no what
uh
i'm kidding
the negroni
first made in 1919 for count camilo
negroni when he swapped the soda water
and his usual drink the americano
virgin
i haven't seen you here before
it's not really in my neighborhood
not your neighborhood where are you from
greenwich greenwich sounds nice
bartenders up there don't give history
lessons well bartenders in greenwich
don't make negronis like this
you want to leave it open or closed
open properly it's only daddy's money
[Music]
you